and he in that family the temple family
is a is a great example of a legacy
family and that can be made if young men
see that it's a possibility all about
women and women too yeah women too but
the thing the thing about women is this
you have to understand there's Primal
parts of us and most often like she was
saying earlier a woman would much rather
be with a strong man she looks up to and
be inside the frame of the family and do
the maternal things the things that
matter the things that the world cannot
live without a mother I think being a
mother is one of the strongest most
impressive hard jobs in on the planet
that baby will not sleep you can't get
any sleep you've been pregnant your
body's torn up and then you still have
to nurture that baby and not get upset
with it not shake it not you know it's
maddening right like let's not belittle
that job one of the most important jobs
on the planet because you're molding the
Next Generation that might be that
Legacy holder for your race or or your
family or whomever